a northeast valley man facing a number
of charges this afternoon accused of
running an illegal breeding operation
police telling us that 27-year-old
malcolm laster was keeping 17 dogs
inside of an apartment near nellis air
force base in unsanitary conditions joe
moeller spoke to an animal rights
advocate who was beyond frustrated he
joins us live at metro headquarters with
how those animals were discovered joe
police discovered these animals out
there they were called out to this
apartment regarding a child neglect
incident that may have happened there
well when they got there they noticed
these around 17 dogs there some of them
were showing signs of starvation
this was at the end of november animal
control officers found 17 dogs including
five puppies according to police there
were severe sanitation problems in the
unit there was also a french bulldog
found in a bathroom according to the
police report it showed signs of
malnutrition and when it was taken for
medical care ended up passing away
animal rights advocate anula wildrich
reacted to the arrest hopefully people
are more aware if they see or hear
something that they would report it
immediately before it got to this point
if they were aware of it
i'm disgusted as anybody would be the
report states the bulldog had given
birth to five puppies at the end of
october and had not received veterinary
care despite last year's statements that
it had begun to lose weight he told
police she would heal naturally when she
was separated from the pups
back out here live police say laster who
lied about having a breeder's license
will now face a number of charges
including the torturing of an animal
reporting live outside of metro
headquarters this evening joe muller
live local now